hi I'm Pete Berg and these are five of
my favorite action sequences of all time
Billy Jack was the first time I ever
remember seeing action or fighting in a
movie and it was Tom Laughlin play Billy
Jack talking about how Wendy and all the
kids at the camp try and tell him to
control his temper and he really tries
but when he sees people humiliated he
just goes berserk Millie Jack just put a
whoop-ass on a group of bad guys and I
was the first fight I ever remember
seeing in a movie officer and a
gentleman was definitely one of the
films that made me want to get in the
business I remember the day after it
came out I shaved my head so I wanted to
look like Richard Gere and I'm Cernan
and gentlemen if you look at that film I
think it's really one
almost a perfect script and for me a
perfect thumb but there were two action
sequences the first is when Richard Gere
and
Debra Winger and their friends are being
chased out of a lake honky tonk blues
bar by some rednecks and Richard Gere
doesn't want to fight but these guys
keep pushing it and he really tries to
get out of the fight and and they push
it and he does like a Taekwondo back
kick and just just breaks this guy's
nose it was the first time I'd seen that
kind of Taekwondo no real serious film
other than Billy Jack and I was like
kind of blown away and then that's the
precursor for the big fight which is the
fight between Richard Gere and Lou
Gossett jr. which was just like a brutal
fight physically and there was so much
emotion these two men had such complex
relationship and this kind of real
love/hate respect disrespect kind of
mutual admiration but a lot of emotional
connection between the two and they just
had this you know for me what was then
probably the most brutal fight I'd ever
seen in a movie so that that's an
awesome movie and a great fight scene
heeey we're gonna what Michael did in
that film I don't think anyone ever done
the the pacing the sound design the
attention to detail the fact that it was
done in broad daylight with you know
empathetic bad guys and an empathetic
cops
dinerral and his team versus Pacino and
his squad was just unprecedented and
really I think is the gold standard for
any gunfight my admiration for Steven
Spielberg is is endless and you know
think that the guy from from et staged
and and choreographed and filmed and
edited the assault on Normandy Beach at
the beginning of Saving Private Ryan is
kind of jaw-dropping for me the detail
again some of the shots I remember
moment where two soldiers were
communicating and they're trying to hear
each other and just when you think mid
conversation one of the soldiers just
gets shot in the head and killed and
that kind of ruthless indiscriminate
violence that it is but what I would
imagine that real kind of combat to be
there's a random shot of a soldier
holding his arm that just these images
stuck with me and my father who served
in the military in Korea and and many
other veterans who have spoken to have
always pointed to that film and
particularly the opening scene the d-day
invasion as one of the most chilling
intense and realistic combat sequences
ever filmed
the steam room the Russian steam bath
scene with Viggo Mortensen where he's
naked and he fights two Russian
assassins I still feels like just one of
the most brutal animalistic carnal fight
scenes I've I've ever seen my hat is
tipped if you go for doing that but ass
naked with all his pride and glory
flying around in the middle of the fight
but it was raw and and you could really
feel it I don't think if you walk away
from the film and you look back a couple
of years later and there's like three or
four seams that really are still with
you that's a success and that that scene
stayed with me for in terms of just the
sheer audacity of that sequence and that
the power of that violence I think it's
probably one of the best hand-to-hand
combat scenes I've ever seen
[Music]